well good evening
today the covet cabinet committee has
approved a number of
measures
that are constitute a careful and
prudent plan to remove alberta's public
health restrictions
and move on from a widespread pandemic
response to get our lives back to normal
before sharing this plan with you i'd
like to address some of the
considerations that informed our
decision today
first it is clear that we passed the
peak of omicron infections about three
weeks ago
and are now seeing the result as
covet-related hospital admissions are
declining
this is good news
and broadly reflects the experience of
other jurisdictions around the world
when it comes to the omicron variant
that's
why countries like england scotland
ireland
denmark
sweden
norway south africa finland and many
others have lifted all or almost all
public health restrictions in recent
weeks
it's also why a growing number of states
across the united states have also
announced the lifting of most public
health measures
including mass mandates
such as the states of california
connecticut
delaware and jersey in new jersey just
in recent days
i note that the problems of saskatchewan
and quebec have followed suit with their
own announcements earlier today
alberta's active cases and rolling seven
day average of new cases has dropped
steadily across the province from about
7 000 a day to approximately 2 000 a day
with total active cases falling from 55
000 to about thirty thousand now
the positivity rate that's the
percentage of pcr tests that come back
positive has also continued to decline
and leading measures like wastewater
surveillance has shown a general
decrease
in most regions of the province
and as i said we see new covet hospital
admissions coming down
another important leading indicator
it's also important to note that because
omicron is more transmissible than
previous variants of covid it is
infecting
more hospital patients who don't
actually have severe covet symptoms
so about 40 percent of patients in the
hospitals who have tested positive for
covet are not actually being treated for
covid they are what we call incidental
cases now they can add some additional
pressure to the system uh but to put
this in context with about 1500 overall
non-icu covet patients
actually only about 900 of them are
being treated for covet or covet as a
secondary condition
it has also and always been the
government's approach to keep public
health measures in place
only so long as they are absolutely
necessary to protect public health and
our health care system
throughout the pandemic alberta's policy
response is always sought to avoid
overwhelming our health system while
minimizing the damaging impact of
restrictions on the broader health of
our society
earlier in the pandemic when vaccine
uptake was much lower
other treatments weren't available and
testing was much harder to come by
so more drastic government interventions
were necessary to keep people safe
and let me just pause to address what
happened in alberta during the delta
wave in august and september the reality
is that we simply didn't have high
enough vaccine rates nor did our
neighbors in saskatchewan that's why we
were hit harder
but all of that has changed now 9 out of
10 albertans over the age of 12 have
some level of vaccine protection
antiviral drug treatments to prevent
severe disease and hospitalizations are
now available and more will come on
stream throughout the year ahead
in other words with what we know now
about the virus and the tools we have to
fight it the threat of covet 19
to public health is no no longer
outweighs
the hugely damaging impact of health
restrictions on our society on people's
mental health on their emotional
well-being on uh
our broader social health
so now is the time to begin learning to
live with kovid
these restrictions have led to terrible
division even amongst families and
friends and
inflamed sometimes tensions in our
communities and neighborhoods
they've disrupted and even destroyed so
many livelihoods
we will never know
we'll never be able to do a full
accounting of the extent of the pain and
hardship that restrictions have caused
but we do know some things we know we
have seen in alberta and across the
developed world a significant increase
in
mental and emotional health challenges
amongst children and adolescents for
example we have seen an increase in
domestic violence
uh we have seen the failure of many
businesses and of course
at the beginning of the pandemic record
high unemployment
and at a time when the world's when the
world should be wide open
uh in uh and full of possibility
and hopefulness uh
and the restrictions associated with it
have robbed thousands of young children
with the simple joys of just being a kid
i was speaking to a young father the
other day who told me that his
ten-year-old daughter
had spent
20 percent of her life under covet
health restrictions
we cannot remain at a heightened state
of emergency forever
we have to begin to heal
and so alberta will move on
but we'll do so carefully
we'll do so prudently
we will do so only if it does not uh
threaten the capacity of our health care
system
so uh our plan will involve three steps
starting with easing restrictions on
activities
and
situations that have been shown to be
lower risk throughout the pandemic
the first starts with children and youth
step one will remove almost all
restrictions affecting children
including removing the mask mandate for
all k-12 students effective this weekend
outside of the school setting kids 12
and under will now be exempt from the
general mask mandate that will continue
to apply in indoor settings for uh
approximately three weeks to come
as i have long said kids have been
subjected to a heavy and i think unfair
burden throughout the pandemic
and it is given the very low threat that
covet 19 poses to the health of children
it is no longer justifiable after two
long years to continue to disrupt and
restrict the normal lives of kids it is
time to let kids be kids and i am
determined to ensure that should we ever
have to come back to any kind of
measures in the future god forbid that
we will not affect the wellness the
freedom and the normal lives of kids
step one will also end the restriction
exemption program in its entirety
effective midnight tonight
now
this is uh i wanted to say this about
the restriction exemption program we
brought this in september
when
our healthcare capacity was under very
severe stress particularly in intensive
care
and at the time
we saw that 90
of our new icu admissions
were amongst unvaccinated people and the
province
was generally under-vaccinated relative
to the rest of canada
we simply had to do something urgent uh
to
prevent a catastrophe in intensive care
enter hospitals generally and we had to
do something to get our vaccine rates up
and so we chose a measure that avoided
shutting down businesses and uh and
places of worship but allowed us to
reduce transmission
while also uh seeing a significant
increase in vaccinations
we went from about
uh 75 vaccination rate
to uh now 90 on first dose and about
seven we went from 68 percent uh to 87
second dose coverage that has made a
huge difference it has saved many lives
and at the same time we have seen a
change in
uh transmissibility the reality is that
with the high level of infectiousness of
the omicron variant plus the waning
protection from infection
of a second dose most albertans got
their second dose eight nine or ten
months ago
we have seen that
the uh that
vaccinated individuals
are still at a high risk of omicron of
infection not of severe outcomes
not of severe disease but of infection
so the point is simply this
that the restriction exemption program
has served its useful purpose it's done
its job
it is no longer leading to higher
vaccination rates in fact we we have
seen our vaccination rates effectively
frozen since early december
and so
our approach to covet must change as the
disease changes
and i believe that's exactly why
the chief medical officer for canada dr
tam
recommended earlier this week that
provinces re-examine programs like their
proof of vaccination programs
that's exactly what we're doing with
this decision
finally step one will remove capacity
limits for all except large capacity
venues of over 500 people
minister copying will provide further
details on these measures
now following these uh
phase one measures we will take
three weeks to carefully monitor trends
with a focus on hospitalizations
if
and only
if we continue to see a downward trend
in hospitalizations
we will then proceed to phase two
our current target date for phase two is
march the first
at which point we plan to lift most
remaining restrictions including the
indoor mask mandate the requirement to
work from home
and remaining capacity limits
following this stage we will take more
time to monitor trends again with a
focus on whether pressure in our
hospital system is manageable
when it is safe to do so we would then
proceed to stage three which would be to
eliminate all remaining public health
measures at that point
so let me add an important caveat
if the current trends reverse themselves
and if we see a significant and
sustained increase in pressure on our
hospitals we may have to pause some of
these measures
but we are determined to get our life
back to normal doing so in a way that
ensures that a hospital bed is there for
everyone who needs one
and that is why a big part of the
upcoming provincial budget later this
month will be about increasing the
capacity of alberta's health care system
because despite the
sometimes heroic efforts of our
fantastic frontline healthcare
professionals over the past two tough
years
the same two years have spotlighted
serious shortcomings in the canadian
health care system which we simply must
address
beginning with the federal government
paying for its share of an increasingly
costly and complex modern health care
system with an aging population
so i very much hope that today's
long-awaited uh optimism uh and uh
this announcement rather gives a sense
of optimism and hope to albertans
i know that some will say this is uh too
much change and that we are moving too
fast
but please keep in mind that we have the
benefit of a few of a few weeks being
behind a few weeks of other
jurisdictions such as the united kingdom
and we can watch what happens as
they return to a regular way of life
for example in britain most restrictions
have been dropped as the omicron wave
has subsided
and aside from
masking and high-risk settings such as
acute care and mandatory isolation for
people with covid there are no other
country-wide mandates in britain
cases and hospitalizations for covet are
continuing to drop there uh and in all
the other countries i mentioned that
have lifted measures with the exception
of denmark
while we are closely monitoring what
other places are doing
and have no doubt please do have no
doubt that our plan
uh is
focused on the data here in alberta
it ensures that we will remain
sure-footed
ever aware of what is happening in our
own health care system and maintaining
protections for those most at risk until
the very end of this plan for getting
back to normal
so we are moving carefully we are moving
with confidence
while we are working towards an end to
restrictive measures and that the damage
that they impose
i want to be clear
none of this is an end to covet 19.
new variants will arrive
and we will still see times when cases
are higher in the province we will
likely also see times when there is
additional pressure on the hospitals
but uh
restrictions mandates and those kinds of
interventions will not and must not
become a permanent feature of our lives
with widespread uptake of the vaccines
as i say close to 87 percent fully
vaccinated with two doses
and nearly uh one and a half million
albertans with having received their
third shot
we are well positioned to live with this
virus
as we do with many other infectious
diseases
the vaccines are doing what we've always
said they would do
to protect us from severe illness and
outcomes
the numbers don't lie over the past
three months the rate of covet 19 deaths
of healthy but unvaccinated individuals
in alberta is over seven times more than
those who have been fully vaccinated
when this uh previously uh healthy but
unvaccinated group is compared to those
who have been fully vaccinated and
boosted with their third shot the
comparison widens the rate of
unvaccinated deaths is approximately 17
times that of people who have been fully
vaccinated and received a third shot
we have been strongly encouraging
albertans to get vaccinated because we
know it works
and we want to keep you and those around
you safe
so now that the overwhelming majority of
albertans are protected we are confident
that we can begin to ease restrictions
while preventing undue strain on our
health care system
and we are not returning to normal all
at once
so please continue to exercise good
judgment
and make smart decisions decisions that
make sense for you and your family
our acute care system is still under
real stress
and we may still see waves of covet 19
come and go as i've said in the months
ahead
but we will always need to protect the
most vulnerable
and may need to adjust as we start this
transition
the virus
has certainly left all of us bruised
but we are not broken
we albertans are never broken we are
always resilient it is time to call on
that resilience as we move in the path
to recovery it is time to remove these
restrictive and damaging health measures
it's time for us to learn to live with
covid as best we can
thank you and i'll now invite mr copping
to provide more details
thank you premier and good afternoon
everyone
as you just heard we have been hard at
work developing a plan for easing public
health measures
we are shifting our approach to managing
covid
it's an approach where we all learn to
live with covid
which we can safely do
with our high rates of vaccinations the
wide availability of butcher shots and
continued protections for the vulnerable
this plan ensures that our healthcare
system will be there for albertans in
their time of need
as i've said before not only is it a
question of actual beds but the
expertise needed to look after patients
in those beds
our health care workers have borne the
brunt of this pandemic
they have carried on
and they have cared for us
we cannot and we must not return to the
same high levels of strain it has
experienced over the past two years
so to all health care workers and
doctors and volunteers caring for
albertans i want to say once again thank
you
this plan we're outlining today
ensures that we will not remove the
public health measures at the expense of
our health care system
the vast majority of albertans have
chosen vaccination and are now fully
protected
just as it was a key component of our
restrictions exemption program
it's now also a major factor that allows
the easing of those restrictions
now that the vast majority of eligible
albertans are fully vaccinated and
boosters continue to work their way into
more arms every day it's clear that our
province is well protected against
severe outcomes such as hospitalization
we also have treatment options such as
antivirals that are now available to us
we considered all of these things when
developing our plan for easing measures
and will continue to consider a myriad
of factors as this three-step plan moves
forward
as premier mentioned i will now provide
further details on the plan
it is a conditions based approach which
requires us specifically to look at the
numbers of new patients admitted to
hospital due to coven 19 over a
sustained period of time
given the current trend in
hospitalizations and transmission
we will move into step one at midnight
tonight
effective at midnight the restriction
exemption program and all its
requirements will come to an end the
exception will be for entertainment
venues
that means that measures on the maximum
number of people per table at
restaurants
liquor service restrictions
closing times and interactive activities
closures will remain in force
but measures limiting food and beverages
while seated at entertainment venues
will be removed
for facilities that are not currently in
the rep
capacity limits will be removed except
for the following
all facilities with capacity of 500 to
1000 which will be limited to a capacity
of 500
and all facilities with a capacity of
more than 1 000
will be limited to 50 capacity
as well effective february 13th at 11 59
p.m
we are removing all mandatory masking
requirements for children under 12 and
mandatory masking in schools will be
removed for all children and youth this
change is delayed in order to give
schools and parents time to adjust
if covet hospitalizations continue to
trend downwards then as indicated by the
premier we will move to step two
effective 11 59 pm on february 28 2022
the following measures will be removed
remaining school requirements
requirements for screening prior to
youth activities
limits on
gatherings general masking requirements
mandatory work from home requirements
capacity limits removed for large venues
and entertainment facilities
and restrictions on closing times and
interactive activities in entertainment
venues
we will move to step three at a later
date contingent on hospitalizations
continuing to trend downward
and this will include covet-specific
continuing care measures being removed
and mandatory isolation requirements
being removed and becoming a
recommendation only
this represents a careful and prudent
approach
to removing public health measures in
alberta
vaccination will continue to be vital to
minimizing the risk of covid and we will
keep working to get as many albertans of
all ages vaccinated with all the doses
they are eligible for including booster
doses
i am happy to announce today that based
on the recommendations of the national
and alberta advisory councils on
immunization
we are expanding the eligibility for
vaccines for youth
youth between the ages of 12 and 17 who
have additional risk factors will be
eligible for third doses as of tuesday
next week
we are also working towards offering
boosters to children between the ages of
5 and 11 who have specific
immunocompromising conditions and will
have more to say about that in the
coming days
these vaccines are safe and will protect
albertans children
i know it will be welcome news to these
young albertans and also to their
parents
bookings for 12 to 17 year olds will be
open next week and more information will
be shared in the coming days
whether your child falls into these
higher risk categories or is already
eligible i encourage all parents and
guardians to get their children
vaccinated
currently nearly half of all alberta's
children aged 11 and under are
vaccinated with one dose and 15 percent
are fully protected with two doses
if you are have if you have been waiting
please don't delay any longer
book your appointment today
through the alberta vaccine booking
system online or through health lake at
eight one one
this is true for all doses not just for
kids and for youth so if you're not yet
vaccinated or fully vaccinated you can
get your first second or third dose
today through most pharmacies in alberta
we are entering a period of transition
between the pandemic and endemic stage
as indicated by the premier there will
be periods of uncertainty
covet 19 will be with us for a very long
time and we will see times when coven 19
affections will be higher than normal
but please rest assured we will continue
to closely monitor the health care
system and we will take action when
necessary to alleviate pressure in
future waves or spikes
that is why we cannot suddenly drop all
the healthy habits and knowledge about
covet 19 that we have developed over the
past two years
our way forward
and its success depends on you
so i'd like to call on all albertans to
continue to follow the rules that are in
place to protect our health care system
and each other
and if you haven't done so already get
your vaccination
thank you for doing your part
and now i'd like to invite dr hinshaw to
the podium for her update
thank you minister and good afternoon
everyone
over the last 24 hours we have
identified
1667 new cases of covet 19 and completed
about 4
260 tests
our positivity rate is about 36 percent
there are currently a total of 1 623
people with covert 19 in hospital
including 129 in the icu
sadly 13 new deaths were reported to
alberta health in the last 24 hours
my condolences go to the family and
friends of these individuals as well as
anyone who has lost a loved one no
matter the cause
alberta education has confirmed that as
of february 8th
seven of the more than 2
500 schools in the province are in
temporary at-home learning to address
operational challenges
fewer than one-quarter of one percent of
schools are currently operating online
as the minister said we know that covet
is not going away
it will continue to be with us for
months and years to come
thankfully we have vaccines that are
very effective at reducing severe
outcomes
and new treatments available as an
addition to help reduce risk
we also have healthy habits that will
remain important
this includes being mindful of our
physical proximity to others and keeping
distance from those outside our
household
practicing good hygiene habits and
staying home when we feel unwell
these simple steps remain important and
can go a long way to helping us stay
healthy and protecting those around us
there has never been one right path to
deal with covid and that remains true
now
every path has advantages and
disadvantages that must be carefully
weighed
as the province moves to eventually
treat covet 19 more like other
infectious diseases it is essential that
each of us continue to do our part to
keep those around us healthy and safe
even as the approach to covet shifts in
our province there will continue to be
measures in place to protect those most
vulnerable to this virus particularly
those in continuing care acute care and
other priority settings
for example masking will remain
mandatory in acute care and continuing
care as an important risk reduction
measure for the foreseeable future
so if you are seeking care or
accompanying someone who is
you will need to wear a mask to protect
yourself and those around you
i ask everyone to be respectful and
patient with those around you as we all
adjust in the weeks ahead
i also encourage albertans to continue
to assess their unique situation and
make personal decisions about their
health based on their own comfort levels
and risk levels
we should all do what is best for us and
our families even if that is different
from those around us
if others need a higher level of
precaution than we are taking for
ourselves we need to be considerate of
their needs
thank you and we're happy to take
questions
thank you dr hinshaw we'll move to the q
a now just a reminder
you can direct your questions to the
premier minister copping or dr hinshaw i
understand we have someone in person in
edmonton so we'll start with them and go
to the phones
never mind we'll start with oh we're
good
kieran levitt with the toronto star
thanks for taking my question this is
for the premiere
um
primer we've got reports that your own
mlas have been negotiating or trying to
negotiate with blockaders down at coots
you're also facing criticism that a lot
of the moves that you're making right
now and the policy decisions are being
driven more by pressure on your
government from that blockade
how do you reconcile those two things
you've got
mlas who are talking with blockaders and
perhaps negotiating with them and
critics who say that especially the
restrictions exemption program being
cancelled at this point is due to
pressure on you from that blockade how
do you reconcile those two things
well they don't need to be reconciled
because they're not true
first of all kieran nobody on behalf of
the government of alberta has been
negotiating with anybody engaged in
illegal actions and uh our solicitor
acting solicitor general minister of
justice sonia savage has made it clear
to all members of government caucus that
uh
they do not cannot negotiate on behalf
of the government of alberta and having
said that there are albertans involved
in that protest who have mlas and i
understand that they've been calling and
contacting their mlas and talking to
them and mlas of responsibility to
listen to their constituents
that is not negotiating it is
elected representatives listening to
their constituents with respect to the
blockade the minister savage and the
rcmp held a news conference to provide a
situation update this afternoon
as i've said consistently we welcome
free
the freedom of people to protest
lawfully and peacefully
but this is not a lawful protest uh this
and other road blockages constitute a
safety hazard uh a serious interference
in the the lives of others it does
economic damage in this case
particularly for ranchers farmers and
agri-food producers
i would point out to those involved in
the blockade i think there are about 38
trucks
i should say semi-trucks at the coots
border cross scene itself
but
we have some 300 000 albertans with
trucking licenses
and about 60 000 commercial trucks that
are licensed for operation in alberta so
something like 99.99
of truckers and trucks are not involved
in that protest and in fact uh that
blockade all it does is inconvenience
thousands of law abiding truckers who
are just trying to make a living who now
have to go to one of the three other
ports of entry between alberta and
montana so we would ask those folks to
uh to stop the blockade we
expect the rcmp to
enforce the law they are responsible for
the operational tactics and how that is
done we respect uh their uh delegated
authority in that respect
uh in terms of the eliminating the
restriction exemption program as i
pointed out karen first of all i think
on december 28 our covid cabinet
committee
came to a unanimous view
that we should lift the restriction
exemption program as soon as it was
feasible to do so because the case for
it was
simply no longer
as compelling as when it was introduced
in september
the program is no longer serving a
useful and compelling purpose i could
not stand in front of albertans tonight
and justify a a continuation
of a program that has done its job
the
restriction exemption program helped to
see vaccination rates go from as i say
on the first dose from about 78 percent
to 90 on second dose from about 68 to 87
but those vaccine rates have been frozen
now
uh since um early mid december so we've
seen a virtually no movement on that
front and what we do see now is um
with the infectiousness of omicron
and with the waning protection
of second doses from
uh infection and and mild disease
uh what we have seen is that
uh the initial purpose of reducing
transmission and high-risk discretionary
social activities is no longer today
what it was in september so we have to
follow the data and not just blindly
ignore it
uh finally karen if what we're doing
here is somehow a response to protests
then
why has england
ireland denmark
sweden
finland
norway south africa
now saskatchewan quebec
done the same thing why are u.s states
that have had harder much harder
lockdowns than alberta over the past two
years like california new jersey
connecticut delaware and many others why
are they right now
lifting all or most measures none of
that has to do anything with a few
trucks uh parked
at the coots border crossing
all of it has to do with the fact that
the disease is changing
and so the approach that we take to
manage it should change as well
and uh can you
detail a little bit what this means for
the program in the future is this
program something that is is completely
off the table now in terms of you know
future iterations of the virus um it you
know is it just on the shelf and
something that you could quickly
re-implement should there be a surge in
infections and and death and some of the
horrible things that we saw during the
delta wave or is this something that you
you you will never bring back
yeah i don't think you're you're
you're either not listening to what i'm
saying here or you're not aware of the
data the data is this
that uh in canada right now
uh unvaccinated people are
almost as likely excuse me i should say
vaccinated people are almost as likely
as unvaccinated people
to
experience a breakthrough infection
now
it is critical to add that the vaccines
are hugely effective
at preventing severe outcomes like
hospitalization and death
and that's why we continue to implore
the on folks who have not yet been
vaccinated to get that that safe and
effective protection
but a program originally designed to
reduce
transmission amongst unvaccinated people
doesn't make sense in a context where we
have such a high level of breakthrough
infections
so this is the data this is the reality
and this is why jurisdictions around the
world are now rolling up their proof of
vaccination programs it is why dr tam
said that provinces should re-examine
proof of vaccination programs uh i think
she said that on saturday
um so no i don't think that this program
can serve any useful purpose
in controlling uh spread now or in the
future unless
unless we were
to
redefine a full vaccination as having
had three shots because we do know that
that third shot the booster shot
having been more recent
and also probably inducing a stronger
overall immune response
is is still somewhat effective at
preventing breakthrough infections so
the only way that a proof vaccination
program would make any practical sense
would be
to as i say make a requirement that
people get a third shot we're only at 43
percent
um third shot coverage amongst the
eligible population in alberta
so
that's 60 percent of the population that
would not be eligible to participate
in discretionary activities
and then what happens if we see
six or 12 months from now
waning protection from breakthrough
infections from a third shot that do we
would we then modify the program to
require that people have a fourth shot i
think it's quite likely
that
uh for the rest of our lives we're
probably going to need to take an annual
coveted shot much like the annual flu
shot every year as you know there's a
slightly modified
um
flu vaccine that is made available and
that is
quite possible uh for covador we are we
then going to attach this is this going
to become a permanent feature of our
lives
i think that's completely implausible
so um the restriction exemption program
has served its useful purpose it's done
its job we thank everybody who's
cooperated with it we thank all of the
the businesses and organizations uh who
have
incurred a lot of costs and
inconvenience
to
to to roll out the program we will
continue to make the qr code available
to those who need to download it if they
are going to other provinces which
require a provincially issued proof of
of complete vaccination or
if they are getting on a flight
and federal regulations require that
they provide a provincially issued proof
of vaccination so we'll continue to
provide that as a convenience
but again at this point it serves no
useful purpose and i cannot see that
changing
thank you premier operator can you
please put through our first caller
thank you kelly kreiderman globe and
mail
hi there premier um if this decision is
based um completely on the data and what
is happening why why end the program at
midnight tonight in such dramatic
fashion instead of giving
restaurants and other public venues a
chance to adapt to the new rules as is
the case for other parts of this plan
well there are no new rules and i think
it would be
a bit of a mugs game kelly to say
keep this going for a few days when we
know that in many areas we're already
having compliance problems uh i think it
would just invite uh very widespread
non-compliance for no useful purpose
um we are at a stage where it's clear
our vaccine numbers on first and second
dose are frozen
i mean they go up by
a few thousand a day but uh if there's
been no meaningful increase now since uh
well before christmas
so uh the rep is is no longer making any
uh measurable difference on the
vaccination rates
and as i've said with the data about
breakthrough infections um they
the idea of using a program like this to
reduce transmission
um in
discretionary
activities is no longer relevant either
so we're just
stating the obvious
and acting on that um
maybe a different way of asking your
question kelly is why why why did it
take us this long
uh the united kingdom uh because i
should say
england the uh
english public health that brought in
their proof of vaccination program
i believe as they started to enter the
omicron wave in late november early
december and then they announced that
they were repealing it about three weeks
ago in mid-january once they were coming
off the omicron peak
they've continued to see cases decline
and those other countries i mentioned
which were hit early by omicron
any one of those countries that had a
proof of vaccination program they've all
repealed them as well
so i think
per dr tam's comments this past weekend
i think that is going to become the norm
uh throughout the world
and kelly do you have a follow-up
yes um but that we are alberta is the
first province to make this move of
completely getting rid of the proof of
vaccine system does that give you some
pride do you think that matches with
public sentiment as we're seeing it
right now in terms of
people's
patience for living with restrictions at
this point in the pandemic
well i'll say this that um
it's not about pride it's just about
being practical and realistic we we
think the program has served its useful
purpose
uh it it really did help us to
prevent the worst possible outcomes from
the delta wave and from omicron it got
our vaccine rates up there's no doubt
that that alone has saved
perhaps hundreds of lives
so i'm not dismissing the the utility
the necessity of the program when it was
introduced it was a difficult decision
as you know um
in the spring of last year every
canadian government including prime
minister trudeau were
dismissing the idea of introducing proof
of vaccination programs for all sorts of
obvious reasons
but we all found ourselves in a
situation
as we moved into the delta wave where we
had to to use every tool at our disposal
and for alberta at least
it was an alternative to widespread uh
lockdowns and shutdowns of businesses
uh and community organizations so
um
it was a tough
uh and
undoubtedly controversial decision but
it was a necessary one
but now as i say we have to read the
writing on the wall this is no longer
serving a
compelling public health purpose and in
terms of being the first well i guess
saskatchewan will follow us this coming
weekend so
we're close to that and i see that
quebec just announced today that they
are lifting over the course of the next
um
three or four weeks virtually all of
their public health measures
uh so uh i think you'll see this become
a fairly widespread trend quite quickly
here
thank you can i just say you asked about
public sentiment i'm sorry justin um
so i do think that we have seen
in recent weeks
a
fairly significant shift in public
uh
tolerance
of damaging public of damaging health
restrictions
and
um
you know those of us who are elected
folks we it's our jobs to listen to
people
and we hear from our constituents we
also see public opinion
research
some done by our government a lot of it
done by media organizations and it's all
pointing in the same direction
which is that
canadians certainly albertans
increasingly are losing patience with
two years
of the disruption of their lives
and are asking
uh
leaders to find a way to move forward
safely
but to get life back to normal
you know
there's a um
epidemiologist
at oxford university
dr ali raghub who i follow and he uh
said i think quite insightfully that
public health restrictions that are
opposed by the majority of the
population do not have a meaningful
impact
this is a point i've tried to make
consistently
about
the responsibility
of
our cabinet
to make a a difficult judgment call
at each state at each stage of kovid
about the public's willingness uh to
comply
and when we see that wilderness break
down
um
what's the point of measures if there's
widespread uh non-compliance it's not
the primary reason we're doing this but
that is part of the context and i think
responsible leaders need to be mindful
of that
thank you premier operator can you
please put to our next caller
thank you andrew lawton true north
good evening premier
for people that own businesses that are
comfortable with requiring proof of
vaccination will they still have the
right in your view under alberta law to
impose a vaccine requirement for
customers moving forward
yes they'll have that right under law
and i guess i would just say that's a
matter of
of the free market andrew if a business
chooses to have
um
a policy of that nature
then
um that may
may appeal to a certain kind of customer
and it may turn away other kinds of
customers that's a commercial decision
at the end of the day
i would love that if we could move away
from all of this
and
no longer have to produce the qr codes
that could get us past the problem
you've raised but
the the
paradox or the problem is
that we have a lot of albertans
who
especially during the cold winter here
uh love traveling and uh and at the end
of the summer time too and as long as
there is a federal requirement for
provincially issued proof of vaccination
we have to offer that as a service
and i got to tell you even then
even if we weren't issuing qr codes
um
i suppose a vendor could
um
going back to the pre-covet days you
know
just just like when you're
visiting certain countries
they want to see if you've been
vaccinated against the uh yellow fever
and you have to produce
these uh slips that prove that prove
vaccination so governments will always
be issuing some kind of proof of
vaccination that's just part of our
responsibility in the healthcare system
and how people use that as their choice
thank you and andrew do you have a
follow-up
i do thank you you mentioned that it's
just an inevitability that we'll see
other variants and obviously you said
your government will continue to monitor
the hospital data we've been down the
road of reopening before when alberta
was open for summer and obviously we
didn't have the widespread vaccination
protection that we have now
but what specifically would be that
trigger point at which we'd have to look
at some level of restrictions again if
there is the confession here that covet
is not over and that a variant that we
might not know the scope of or the power
of could come and hit us
the truth is we simply don't know
uh if we take
cues from history
from
epidemiological history
we can i think
reasonably hope
that uh
stars cov2 covet 19
will go in a
similar
uh direction as the spanish flu which as
you know
took something like 50 million not lives
between 1918 and 1920
but then moved to endemicity
um
if
partly because there were
uh new variants
that may have been more transmissible
more transmissible were less severe
um and because of wider population
protection
both from
uh
the immune response to prior infection
as well as vaccines
so we have far more
effective and widely available vaccines
now than ever before
coming from out of omicron we also have
far more people
uh with
antibodies acquired from prior infection
and uh and so i think it's reasonable to
hope
that
we won't
be
we won't get into a much worse situation
but we don't know that for sure
so we simply have to be prepared
for what the future may come at us what
what may come at us in the future excuse
me um
now having said that i think it is
incumbent on governments of all stripes
in all jurisdictions
to do whatever they can
to
avoid relying on the blunt instrument of
damaging restrictions
as a primary
response
to
potential future waves with more severe
outcomes um and by that i mean in the
canadian context
we
have to fix our health care system first
and foremost
it is
outrageous
that canada's public health care system
is in the top
quartile
of the
oecd in terms of cost but the bottom
quartile
of the oecd the developed world
in terms of
per capita beds
per capita physicians
surgical wait times diagnostic wait
times etc
this is not
the fault
of our brilliant
and through covet often heroic frontline
healthcare workers
nor is it because of a lack of money
we are as i say the top of the towards
the top of the developed world when it
comes to healthcare expenditures
but we have to
face the fact
that we have had
too little capacity to address a
situation like this
that is something that we will be
addressing forthrightly in our
forthcoming budget and it's incumbent on
the federal government to do so as well
uh minister copied and i will have a lot
more to say about that so healthcare
capacity first and foremost uh and and
secondly
um
using everything that is being learned
about covet 19
to provide better and more widespread uh
treatments
and i think we'll see that throughout
the year with a more successful the
completion of more successful trials
on antivirals and other medications
which can act as a additional tool
uh on top of vaccines to help us cope
with any future
waves that are more severe
thank you premier operator can you
please put through our next caller
chris varko calgary
the canadian harold of independent
business did a study that showed pretty
much an even split between business
owners on the usefulness and their
support for the vaccine passport what
would you say to businesses if they want
to continue to use the qr code or want
to continue to require customers to be
vaccinated
well as i said it's
okay and if
businesses vendors choose to adopt their
own policy
and ask people to provide some proof of
vaccination uh
as long as we're issuing those qr codes
uh i suppose they can do so but
uh
i
to be frank i do hope the federal
government
will
in the foreseeable future
and some of the
public health theater
that has informed i believe uh some of
the travel restrictions i spoke to this
last friday on the conference call for
the council of the federation
and um
you know in a world where in north
america for example we know there are
tens of millions of current active
omicron
infections
so um
the notion that
that these restrictions can somehow uh
reduce transmission uh is
uh nonsensical in my view increasingly
nonsensical but as long as the federal
government keeps that requirement of
four peop for
the federally regulated travel to
require a provincially issued qr code we
will issue those codes for the
convenience of albertans and if people
choose to offer uh to show that of
vaccination to
a business they i guess that's their
choice they're welcome to do so
and chris do you have a follow-up
yes just a point of clarification and
then a question um can you be a little
clearer on the restrictions on closing
times and alcohol service and when those
exactly will be removed that's my
clarification question and then just in
terms of um the broader question of many
business owners is what is the province
prepared to do to try and install
confidence and consumers to get back out
there
so the restrictions on the operation of
hospitality businesses such as the
11 pm
limit on alcohol service 12 pm closing
time
uh a maximum of 10 people seated at one
table
uh a prohibition on um
activities like for example billiards
and darts those restrictions that were
brought in december will continue
until we come to
phase two
of this uh back to normal plan
which we hope will
uh start on march the first
so these are this underscores that we
are proceeding uh with caution
uh the good news for those operators is
that um
the uh
proof of vaccination program ends
midnight tonight but we will ask them to
maintain uh those other measures in
place until
at least the march the first
i know that you and another journalist
have asked about businesses who want to
keep this in place i think it's
important to understand
is it very rarely do rural media get to
ask or get in the queue or ask questions
of these things for some reason
but
i think it's important to recognize
that in many
areas of rural alberta with lower levels
of vaccination
the restriction exemption program has
been extremely tough
on many of the hospitality businesses
for a couple of reasons one
in some cases 30 or 40 percent
of their
local population are not vaccinated so
that is a huge blow to their consumer
demand and secondly it's often created
really tense situations with uh with
their community members so uh this is
something that um
i know
small business owners in rural alberta
have been desperately hoping for
and i want to acknowledge uh mlas from
rural opera for being a very strong
voice
for
their constituents in this regard
you premier we have time for three more
operator can you please put through our
next caller
rick bell calgary sun
good afternoon premier and minister and
dr hinshaw um
i'm not going to get rid of my vaccine
passport yet premier because we still
have a vaccine passport bylaw in calgary
and we still have and we'll have a
masking bylaw in calgary and i know
you've answered this before but
it was an answer i don't think a lot of
people really have a lot of confidence
in that you'll take a look at it and
maybe sometime down the line and maybe
when the ledge gets back in session
something will happen
um
what are you prepared to do now
whether it's talking to the
mayors of the city what are you actually
planning to do to ensure that
the
over 2 million people that live in
calgary and edmonton
will be on the same page
that you are on
well rick
we haven't made any decisions i've
indicated that's an issue we're going to
look at closely i've asked our ministers
of municipal affairs
health
and justice and solicitor general
to come forward with
options and policy advice on this issue
in the past
we have
uh tolerated uh
municipal
bylaws on on public health matters
uh we've tried to be collaborative and
respectful
and as you know
we do try to respect as uh as much as we
can the the
delegated powers of municipalities
but
i'd really like to
uh
have a a longer conversation
uh with particularly the big city mayors
who have spoken to this issue
because i'd like to know if it is their
intention
to create an entire
entirely separate
municipal public health policy
that is different and apart from that of
the province i think that would be a
serious problem
um
and so that's something that we will
talk to them about we'll be listening to
calgarians and edmontonians on this
issue we haven't made any decisions but
i i would just say this
i think
turning a public health policy like this
into some kind of a of a local political
football is not helpful
uh it's not conducive to the to public
uh
confidence in the public health uh
parameters
or in the clarity but what the rules are
from one part of the province to another
um
and and finally you know it's the
province is responsible
for administering the health care system
which has got to be the central focus of
all of this
and i think perhaps we've been a little
more sensitive than
some in in in uh of these voices of
municipal government about the damaging
effect of restrictions
we're responsible for balancing all of
these
uh can all of these different
considerations
happy to have a respectful discussion uh
with the mayors and others about this um
and and to look more closely at the
issue but we're keeping our options open
and rick do you have a follow-up
yes uh well at least now i now i i know
that everybody will be writing that we
still have vaccine passports in calgary
and edmonton tomorrow morning um
a lot of people you know uh public
opinion you talked about already and i'm
gonna concentrate on the opinion of your
mlas
opinion of a lot of people who
self-identify as small c conservatives
and do you think
that what you have outlined today
will help you keep your job on april 9th
because there is a lot of
there was a lot a lot of pushback
or push forward to get
a restriction
uh lifting a restriction plan in place
so do you think this will actually help
you
win back the hearts and minds of small c
conservatives and even people in your
caucus
rick this is nothing today's
announcement is
about a careful plan to move forward uh
to get our lives back to normal
while ensuring that we protect the
health care system
our goal from day one on covet has been
to
protect the hospitals from being
overwhelmed while limiting the damaging
effect of restrictions
obviously
that
difficult balancing act
has upset some people from time to time
at both ends of the spectrum
i think this government has been more
widely criticized from those who believe
that we have been too reluctant
to resort
to damaging restrictions then it has
been criticized by people who
don't like restrictions
so
we have been trying
our level best
to
have a balanced approach
and i think alberta's done pretty well
on that account
i would point out for example
that in this omicron wave
we have had a
lower level of hospitalization and a
much lower level of covert deaths
than the province of quebec
that went to a hard lockdown including
curfews shutting schools
and businesses
while we have kept virtually everything
uh
in fact i can't think of anything that's
that hasn't been allowed to operate
over the past uh several months
really since last spring
yes there have been some limitations and
yes the proof of vaccination program has
been an annoyance but it has saved
hundreds of lives and left let allowed
us to keep all these businesses and
organizations open and operating safely
so i make
no apology for that
uh
you know people
expect
responsible leaders to make tough
decisions
that's what we did in introducing
the restriction exemption program
and now we're making another tough
decision that some people won't like but
i think it's the right one
which is
uh to see that the program has has
outlived its useful purpose
i'll
remind you rick what i said to the very
first question here
which is
uh
if this
today's announcement if this is about
domestic political considerations then
why is it effectively the same
announcement made
over the past month by england ireland
scotland
denmark
norway
finland
south africa
sweden
increasingly by us states blue states
and now increasingly by canadian
provinces including quebec and
saskatchewan
um
i i know it might be difficult for you
but
maybe separate the politics out of this
for once
thank you premier operator can you
please play through our second last
caller
thank you tony sesquis cbc
oh yes hi thanks for taking my question
i'm just wondering um someone had
mentioned earlier in this news
conference that that hospitalizations
were trending down i'm just worried if
someone can flush that out and and
provide some hard numbers
sure so
we showed you that
the
admissions
the rate of new covet-related
hospitalizations has come down
from about um
36 per million
to
uh about 27
cases per million and uh be
over the uh the last sin i think that
process started on about january the
24th
and so we can get you more specific data
on that of course these admissions are
the uh a key leading indicator uh
because this shows us what will be
happening in the hospitals
uh as
as current cases
are resolved you'll see uh the total
numbers in hospital coming down i should
also point out
that
right now
as of
7 52 this morning
we had
five thousand three hundred and forty
six
uh non-icu
uh
patients
in
our uh in our hospitals
and
that is uh below the number that we have
had
very often at this time of year
uh for example in 2018 and 2017
that that number was higher in alberta
than it is now
uh we are currently at
eighty
uh
seven percent of uh occupancy of non-icu
beds which again is below where we
normally are at this time of year
normally it's north of ninety percent
um with respect to icu occupancy
we
um are now at um
total icu patients
of 198
which is it is above our baseline
capacity but well below our current
surge capacity so we're at 82 percent
uh of our available ic of our
173 available icu beds that are
currently occupied um there is real
pressure on the system we've been making
that clear
that pressure has is primarily coming
from
uh higher than average
uh absenteeism due to covet infections
and self-isolation protocols
and of course coveted patients do take
up more space
again because of isolation protocols in
the hospital so this is
putting very real pressure on the system
not denying that but um we are seeing
admissions come down just as we are
seeing the total active cases come down
uh the average daily new case has come
down uh the positivity uh rate come down
and uh
on a province-wide basis we're seeing
the uh wastewater data trends come down
as well
and tony do you have a follow-up
yeah yeah i'm just worried you know
premier if i could ask you you know
there's not much doubt it's been a
pretty polarizing couple of years
uh in a lot of the different respects in
this province i'm just wondering if i
can get your thoughts on
what it might take or what what will
happen
to maybe
i don't know if the word is smooth that
out but but
how do we move forward from here
great question and one of the things
that concerns me most has been that
division and that polarization
uh and so i would just
urge
albertans how about you know everybody's
got some grievances
uh about policy
about the opinions of relatives
of
i know i know friendships that have been
broken up over this i know families
where relatives close
relatives are not talking to one another
anymore
because of differences in covet policy
i hear every day
about physical altercations
in stores and restaurants over things
like masks and proof of vaccination
this is one of the
tragedies of
this terrible two-year period
you can't really quantify it but we all
know it's real
i guess what's happening right now with
these protests and the reaction to it is
just an example of that
so
i've tried to say all along that we need
a lot of patience for one another
and
i i would i am concerned about this you
know i see some of the commentary
from
people who are opposed to lifting the
restriction exemption program i've seen
the following kind of comment a lot on
social media lately people saying well i
don't want to go to a restaurant
and have to sit next to somebody who's
unvaccinated
that sentiment deeply concerns me
treating fellow people as though they
are somehow unclean
listen
i've been
amply clear that i think everybody
should avail themselves of the
protection of safe and effective
vaccines and that the choice not to get
vaccinated is not just a personal choice
it does have social consequences
but it's never okay
to treat people like that to
stigmatize people in that way and in a
way it kind of reminds me of the
uh attitudes
that circulated
in north america in the mid 1980s about
people with hiv aids
that there's this notion that they they
had to be kind of
distanced
for health reasons
listen this is
uh
this is a terribly divisive attitude
so
yes we encourage people to get
vaccinated but treat treating people who
have made a different decision
as though they are
unwelcome as members of our society
is not acceptable
and on this i would call i would join
the chair of the quebec liberal caucus
and calling on the prime minister
to tone down some of the divisive
rhetoric one of the first and most
important responsibilities of the prime
minister
is to be a uniter
now of course we can't get past all of
the differences of opinion and divisions
on covet policy
but uh
surely
uh the prime minister could find it in
his heart
to stop
categorizing um
millions of people
with
terms like misogynist and racist i think
that's putting fuel on the fire of the
social division which we need
to heal from and move on from
thank you premier operator can you
please put through our final
thank you
radio canada
hi thank you for taking my questions
please
um
[Music]
do you have a follow-up
[Music]
[Music]
a
uh
thank you everyone that concludes our
press